the nintendo 64 was quite a divisive
console when it was released with the
gaming industry shifting from 2d sprites
to that pixelated 3d goodness nintendo
made some bizarre choices with the n64
such as sticking with cartridges just as
their newest competitor playstation
adopted cds i mean isn't it ridiculous
to think of someone still using
cartridges today
nintendo also went with let's say
an endearing controller design how how
do i hold it there's a button in the
back how do i hit the deep my fingers
don't bend that way why is this joystick
so sticky why is it so stupid
[Music]
not to mention it's more child-friendly
focus in a gaming market that was
beginning to demand the more dark and
gritty experiences you know
for adults
[Music]
yet while these choices did cause
nintendo to lose a dominant position in
the market the nintendo 64 is often one
of the most fondly remembered consoles
by many gamers today
from blowing into the cartridge as you
desperately hope that it removes the
dust to rumble packs that gave you a
heart attack the n64 will always have a
soft spot and are now weakened hearts
and especially in the heart of this
particular video producer yet what truly
makes the n64 stand out in our memories
is the games so with the n64 celebrating
its 25th anniversary this year wait 25th
fan over that can't be wait let me just
no no no no no no no no no no it can't
be 25 years what have i done with my
life how could i
breathe
let's tackle now existential crisis
later anyways since this is the n64's
25th anniversary let's rank the top 15
n64 games as always this is my jesse
earl's personal great fun time cool list
so if your favorite hidden gems like
clay fighters 63 and a third or superman
64 didn't make the cut it's just because
we have different tastes also it's
because i hate everything that you love
and with that said let's get on with the
list
number 15 mario tennis while it wasn't
the first mario sports game for n64 or
even the first time gaming's favorite
plumber picked up a racket mario tennis
was by far mario's most refined athletic
outing the game introduced a new control
scheme where you press one or both of
the a and b buttons allowing you to make
the ball spin in different ways adding
in a sense of strategy to the game yet
it still managed to maintain the arcadey
easy to pick up and play feel that has
continued to define all of mario's
sports titles to this day the game also
let you transfer your character's stats
from the gameboy color version which
while gimmicky was the exact type of
gimmick made for weird and esoteric
elementary school kids like
some people not anyone specific but
speaking of weird and esoteric the real
reason that mario tennis managed to get
on this list is for one simple thing
the introduction of waluigi
[Music]
yes mario tennis was the game that gave
birth to the walking nightmare that is
waluigi and i think we can all agree
that that in and of itself earns mario
tennis a spot on this list you're doing
god's work mario tennis god's work
number 14 conquers bad for a day despite
its poor sales conker's bad fur day is a
good time similar in style to rare's
other 3d platformers of the era though
with much more vulgar humor bad fur day
has you exploring numerous varied levels
to collect items and complete different
challenges in order to progress but what
set conker's bad for a day apart was its
style tone and
humor
let's go with that all i wanna do is
pollinator
oh
she's got stupid moves like you wouldn't
believe
what do you mean i thought you said you
had big yeah you play as the eponymous
squirrel conker trying to rescue his
girlfriend barry after a night of binge
drinking the game is filled with endless
amounts of this type of risque humor
such as an opera singing pile of feces
or a storyline that involves a war
between squirrels and nazi-like teddy
bears called the t to datsy's ted tds
oh
teddies yeah got it teddy's a nut yeah
no that well the story isn't for
everyone and a lot of its humor hasn't
aged let's say
well the game has certainly developed a
cult following and remains if nothing
else a memorable experience right that's
it piss off
i've got some cats to see i love these
things i hate those bloody cats
everywhere
number 13 resident evil 2. so i know
what most of you are thinking
resident evil 2 came out on the n64 yes
it most certainly did
and yes it's clearly the inferior
version compared to its playstation
cousin its backgrounds lacked definition
and character voices sounded mult by
comparison stop it sherry's in serious
trouble william implanted her with his
embryos there's no telling when they'll
pupate and if that happens then sherry
won't
won't
what
honestly it's just simply incredible
angel studios was able to port two cds
worth of game and fit it into a single
cartridge in the first place despite
this though resident evil 2's brilliance
still shines through even in a
compromised state leon and claire's
intertwined stories through the zombie
infested raccoon city still remained a
triumph of puzzle solving and horror
while the gameplay hasn't aged perfectly
especially in light of the game's recent
remake re2 on the n64 expertly brought
the evils of the umbrella corporation to
the homes of numerous rabbit fans and
arguably paved the way for nintendo and
capcom's blooming relationship that led
to a particular future resident evil
classic don't shoot i'm a human
number 12 pokemon snap pokemon snap is
one of those love it or hated
experiences while some found the game
where you play as a photographer trying
to gain points by getting interesting
photos of pokemon while sitting in an on
the rails cart to be incredibly boring
others found it to be charming and
endearing the joy of the game came from
getting a chance to see your favorite
pokemon out in the world
living their best lives and then
throwing apples at them and laughing as
you perpetuate the animal cruelty
inherent to the franchise yet the
surprise of finding a new secret by
playing with your items or finding a
cool pokemon evolution was truly
satisfying now if only mew would stay
still for a single moment just stupid
flying magic mouse is he a mouse i guess
he's an alien whatever he looks like a
mouse it's fine
number 11 perfect dark the spiritual
successor to rare seminal first person
shooter goldeneye 007 perfect dark show
that fps games could continue to evolve
despite the n64's controller the
campaign followed joanna dark an
espionage agent in the far far far far
far future of 2023 trying to take down
datadyne an evil corporation that is
allied with reptile-like aliens to
become the biggest company on earth wait
does this explain jeff bezos
could it be you overestimated your
influence over him anyways while the
story was solid like goldeneye the
multiplayer dominated the conversation
but it was the addition of campaign
co-op that truly made this game
memorable and while often forgotten
makes it still hold a place in gaming
history and possibly its future with a
new game in the franchise set to come
out soon
let's let's just forget that
other one
even happened didn't anybody tell you
smoking kills
yeah
yeah virus detected
me and my big mouth
number 10 diddy kong racing diddy kong
racing is often overshadowed by the
success of mario kart 64. but in many
ways it's the superior kart racing game
first and foremost dkr featured a
variety of vehicle types allowing you to
choose between a car hovercraft or
airplane years before the mario kart
series made similar edition the copycats
the game's adventure mode was also
unique allowing gamers to explore a fun
hub world and choose how to progress the
story these smaller maps also allowed
for more bite-sized experiences and the
boss battles were fairly inventive for a
kart racer you could also play as banjo
which is just cool yet while it has more
positives than mario kart it also has
more negatives the game has less item
variety more bugs and some frustrating
mechanics
despite these missteps though diddy kong
racing still manages to forge its own
identity despite the similarities to its
italian plumber rival
number nine star wars rogue squadron
while rogue squadron came out a few
years before the endless shovelware
tying games that define the next
generation of consoles it still set the
bar for how excellent a franchise game
could be inspired by empire strikes
back's hoth battle the game cast you in
the role of a rogue squadron pilot
working for the rebel alliance and
allowed you to pilot the iconic x and y
wings through a story that took you to
all the classic star wars locales the
story even went beyond the events of the
return of the jedi as the rebels finally
brought down the wounded empire you were
tracking down all the like the last
little people that were sort of in
control of the empire it was just so
cool
we were all so excited to see what
happened after return of the jedi back
then
the innocence while it was later
outshined by its gamecube sequels rogue
squadron still remains an iconic game
number eight goldeneye double 07. on the
topic of tying games only one has so
completely revolutionized an entire
genre and that is 007 goldeneye while
its campaign which let you kill a
beautifully pixelated sean bean in a
retelling of the movie was certainly a
standout thanks to incredible set pieces
and level design what people remember
most about goldeneye 7 was its
multiplayer friends would gather round
the n64 try to untangle the chords and
yell over and over again who got to play
his odd job and fight each other on
four-player split screen an experience
that would become a staple of fps gaming
for years to come now if only i could
have gotten my brother to stop screen
looking the cheating jerk
number 7 super smash brothers speaking
of multiplayer though super smash
brothers is the game that finally
finally
finally gave nintendo fans what we had
always wanted the ability to have our
favorite characters beat the ever loving
crap out of each other endless after
school hours were spent with friends
screaming at each other as they made
iconic characters like mario link and
kirby knock each other off inventive and
creative stages while the controls would
become more refined in later entries in
the franchise this game was a truly
masterful execution of an ambitious
vision except for whoever gave donkey
kong his walk grab that person just
wanted to see the world burn
number six mario kart 64.
you knew this had to be here mario kart
64 managed to make kart racing
incredibly accessible with its rubber
banding methodology which emphasized
using varied items and abilities to keep
even novice players in the running until
the very last moment
blue shell even beyond that its tracks
are always varied and unique and the
game even packs in a few fun extra
multiplayer modes like balloon pop to
keep things fresh with your friends
honestly the only negative i can say is
that this is clearly the most boring
rainbow road in the entire franchise i i
think we can all agree with that i mean
what's it oh look there's the characters
up in the stars
oh and what the hell were with those
coconut things that wanted to murder you
if you went off the track in the donkey
kong level i still worry if they're
chasing me they're in my dreams
what were they
well it's certainly not the uh the best
in the series there's no denying that
mario kart 64 is the franchise's most
iconic entry
number five banjo-kazooie
if super mario 64 established the
mechanics of the collect-a-thon
platformer banjo-kazooie proved that the
genre could also have heart and humor to
this day few games match the charm and
wit that banjo-kazooie naturally evokes
the quest of this sweethearted banjo at
his wisecracking bird friend kazooie to
rescue his sister from the evil witch
grunty is embarrassingly littered with
memorable characters and unique
locations each level has its own flavor
and charm filled to the brim with clever
platforming and smart puzzles plus who
doesn't swoon after hearing the adorable
noises these characters make
come on it's so cute
okay that was that was my that was my
grunty impression um i'm sorry moving on
number four majora's mask after the
sweeping adventure that was ocarina of
time majora's masks designers decided to
take zelda in a darker more existential
direction majora's mask sees link trying
desperately to stop the moon from
crashing into the earth forcing him to
continually reset the world into a three
day time loop while the stakes certainly
felt grand the themes were more personal
with the time loop gameplay forcing you
to get to know the intricacies and
idiosyncrasies of the doomed denizens of
clocktown as well as explore a story
that many fans theorize mirrors the
stages of grief so light stuff
majora's mask was certainly a risk after
the success of ocarina but one that paid
off with some fans considering it to be
their favorite game in the franchise you
know if they weren't traumatized by the
horrifying mask salesman
number three banjo-tooie i know i know i
know i can already hear a ton of you
yelling at me you like banjo-tooie over
kazooie yes i do and while i totally
understand why some folks love the
original more this is my list and you're
wrong certainly banjo-tooie is a less
refined experience than its predecessor
with annoying backtracking sections over
long repetitive cutscenes and
let's say problematic depictions of
indigenous peoples of the united states
culture
now we don't have time to unpack all of
that yet tui also showcases the rare of
the n64 era's growing ambition and
desire to keep pushing further each
world feels more unique than the last
the boss battles felt grand the puzzles
are clever and the gameplay continues to
vary with you unlocking new
transformations and abilities right to
the end even further the interlocking
levels highlight a unique approach to
metroidvania type game design one that
forces you to think about how best to
approach each world not to mention this
game doubles down on the darker humor
making for an interesting balance
between the whimsical feeling of the
first game and the brashness of conker's
bad fur day it's a fantastic game that i
often return to and if there's any hill
i'll die on is that banjo-tooie is the
best game in the franchise i will die on
this hill just like bottles did
number two super mario 64.
if you haven't gotten out your
pitchforks and torches let's talk about
another excellent platformer because as
a launch title it's truly amazing how
super mario 64 not only managed to
create an entire genre of 3d platforming
collectathons but still manages to be
one of the best there is this
masterpiece managed to feel wide and
deep with seemingly endless levels to
explore and each star feeling just hard
enough to collect yet deceptively simple
once you figured out how to acquire them
making collecting every one of them feel
like a true victory peach's castle also
remains one of the best settings in
gaming history thanks to the many
secrets hidden in its walls making after
school discussions with friends a key
part of its appeal super mario 64 could
easily go down as n64's best game
super mario 64 could easily go down as
n64's best game
one second
william shut up i'm trying to do a big
build-up and dramatic conclusion here
alright
sorry about that super mario 64 could
easily go down as n64's best game if
only it wasn't for our top pick
number one quest 64. hell yes quest 64.
i mean how can you not love copy and
paste rooms or that you can't even save
without buying an expensive peripheral
this game is just sheer perfection
okay sorry evans can you imagine
anyways seriously
number one ocarina of time to be honest
i'm not a zelda gal beyond the n64
entries i've never really been able to
get into the franchise but even i'd be
hard-pressed to pick a more epic moment
in my gaming memory than stepping out
into hyrule field for the first time
realizing the grand adventure that
awaited me
and also wondering what the hell those
spinny clock things were that were
trying to murder me but what follows is
a true masterpiece of game design with
an epic yet heartbreaking story that
spanned across time told through dark
and endlessly clever dungeons story
moments iconic music clever game
mechanics and so much more the journey
through hyrule is not for the faint of
heart yet it remains the n64's most
defining gaming experience and for that
it will remain number one
[Music]
also [ __ ] those chickens am i right
while it was far from a perfect console
in the end the n64 had many surprises
while games like super smash brothers or
mario kart 64 were simply laying the
groundwork for more refined experiences
that would come in later generations
games like ocarina of time banjo-tooie
and super mario 64 still remain
eminently playable to this day and their
impacts on games and the people that
make them can still be felt
reverberating through the modern
landscape of gaming and for that the n64
will never be forgotten even after
another 25 years
well now that the list is done let me
just say i hear you i included conker's
bad fur day and not donkey kong 64. and
how could i forget f-zero x or our paper
mario or star fox 64
jet force gemini waveracer 64. where is
waveraces64 jesse i know i hate me too
for this list this was honestly one of
the hardest lists for me to make and i
earnestly would love to see your list in
the comments below but regardless thank
you for watching and don't forget to
give us a thumbs up if you liked it and
sub for more gaming content now back to
quest 64.
[Music]
[Music]
foreign